thank you
yes anxious but I present
[Music]
so I have a conference that I need to
present in tomorrow as part of my
medical school degree NSS so I have to
pass it if I want to become a doctor so
I'm here in the library to print out
some stuff to design the display I'm
given at the conference
[Music]
there's actually no one left at the uni
other than medical students because
every other degree has finished their
exams and gone home started their summer
only medical students still have exams
to do but hopefully we'll be done soon
as well I can't wait this conference is
part of a this conference is part of our
doctors as teachers unit you teach
something and get feedback on it and for
that I made a video on skincare and I
even posted it on my channel to
hopefully help as many people as
possible and I'll link it here if you
want to watch it but now I need to edit
the transcripts of what I'm going to say
at the conference and practice as much
as possible
um by the way the presentation is timed
so I can only speak for five minutes and
if I exceed the time it's not good so
I'm going to time myself now
why did I choose this topic well firstly
I'm really interested in dermatology and
I've suffered from acne in the past and
at the time I read lots of papers on
PubMed about skincare
time to go because it's my flatmate Emmy
birthday and we're going to celebrate it
together and watch Love Island and eat
cake and stuff and I don't want to be
late for that
myself
this guy got rid of it
yeah
the garlic from the garlic bread I'm
really excited it's really good thank
you it's because yeah it's organic good
morning
[Music]
I need to wash my hair before the
conference and get ready in one half
hours honestly I do get anxious when I
present in front of people but what I
find useful is if I feel good about my
physical appearance then I also feel
confident when I'm presenting so it
affects my mindset and performance
positively that's why you want to look
put together and washed his hair but
before washing my hair I always try to
do some kind of exercise because hair
washing is a tricky cue for exercising
in my mind if you've read that I make
habits so you know what I'm talking
about but there is this habit stacking
phenomenon so you link a habit you want
to develop like exercising with the
habits you already have like hair
washing and this helps me to regularly
exercise and I've been doing this for
the last two years
[Music]
so I won't worry
we're done oh my God I'm so red
I just want to get in the shower wash my
hair wash my body and be nice and clean
for the conference super happy that I
exercise
so I've been using kids shampoo and
conditioner bars because they're bottle
free and environment friendly first I
emulsify the shampoo bar before I put it
on my hair
so it properly gets rid of the sweat and
dirt from the run you get your money's
worth with these bars because one bar
should last you 100 washes so you also
save two plastic bottles with this one
bar which is amazing and it's cruelty
free vegan and it has no sulfate
parabens or phthalates for me I have
naturally textured and frizzy hair
that's why I especially love their
conditioner bars it makes my hair soft
and moisturized and calms down the frizz
I just apply the conditioner bars like
I'm painting my hair as you can see here
it's also rice water-based which helps
with hair growth and strengthening you
can use the link in my description box
or my code to get 25 off your first
order they ship in the US and
internationally to over 27 countries
including the UK Canada Australia New
Zealand thank you to kids for sponsoring
my hair feels super soft since I sweat I
forgot the most important thing I'll
need to put as much deodorant as I can
because I know I'm going to sweat so
much I try to present myself as smart as
possible I'm just wearing a blank white
White Lake black trousers
you know we're here to set up the
display now
[Music]
yeah
it's in the middle
it's funny
it's finished designing my display it
looks okay honestly I just need to pass
it anyway
what was your teacher did it on the
ukranial nerve exam for the awesome
dance
and you have all this food yeah
hello
beautiful with me
is a really good cop
guys I'm just gonna fake by the way fake
conferencing just ignore me I'm enough
now and this is what it is
97 of people actually after that I'm so
desperate to find a solution for my acne
that really affected my confidence yeah
so it's moisturizer on down skin I'm so
warm you'd think as a Mediterranean
person I'd be able to deal with UK warm
weather but no no
before I start studying for the last
exam of the year I'm going to watch
Netflix or I might just nap
oh my God yes maybe we could go get some
like kebab
hi who's your Oscar I didn't used to
pass the sauce it kinda relieves the
stress because I pass like all the other
Oscars but I still kind of feel I'm
gonna do well but also you can relax
with it it's the last exam of the year
she's finished by the way she's finished
with med school
like you'll get that all the time I
haven't seen a camera before I can't be
yeah
stressful man
[Music]
Oscar revision time yet bye in less than
14 hours I will be a free woman tomorrow
I have my last practical exam of medical
school ever they're called Oscars
actually all the other Medics except us
fourth years are finished so we're
closing off the exam season this year
because it's the last exam I feel more
pressure to do well because I don't want
to ruin anything last minute but
hopefully I'll be okay I usually
practice with friends for this exam
because one of us can act as a patient
whilst the other one can act as a doctor
vice versa but depending on the friend I
practice with it can actually cause more
distractions and confusion and stress
rather than help me in my learning so
over the years I've learned to practice
with a few friends who I know their
style of group work and the friends who
will give me constructive feedback and
considering how less time I have until
the exam tomorrow it will will be more
efficient for me to practice with a fake
patient afterwards I'll practice some
history taking with my flatmate James
anyway
[Music]
if I have a chat to you about what's for
you in here and examine you as well yes
of course dear thank you can I just
confirm your name and date of birth
please Maria bear 22nd of the 11 39 I'm
pretty awesome all right lovely to meet
you Maria have a look at your mouth now
all right say ah for me okay
I'm just going to have a quick listen as
well
lovely thank you hello
I'm done practicing for now I don't
think I'm going to film anything
tomorrow morning because I can already
feel the stress coming over me I'm just
gonna focus on going through everything
really quickly before the exam
see you guys on the other side and wish
me luck
can't wait to go home
so so happy and grateful that it went
well
all right go we were in Oscars and now
we're three women
that feeling of what's next there is
nothing next and it feels great